there is a bitcoin fund that has
returned 65 000
that's right dan moorhead and pantera
dan used to run a macro fund and in 2013
2014 time frame he started to learn
about bitcoin he decided to set up a
bitcoin fund and that fund has been
absolutely gigantic in terms of its
return now that pantera bitcoin fund
since 2013 65 000
dan's got a very interesting background
he started trading bonds at goldman in
the 1980s not 1908 in the 1980s he
started pantera in 2003 that grew to
about a billion dollars in assets as a
traditional macro hedge fund he then
learned about bitcoin for the first time
in 2011 his brother looking out for him
said hey big dog i gotcha go check out
this bitcoin thing and then of course
they started the bitcoin fund in 2013
and then have started many many other
funds they now manage a couple of
billions of dollars when you look at the
performance very rare do we ever get to
see the performance of various funds but
they have the returns i believe this was
the bloomberg article went ahead and
showed this their early stage token fund
had a lifetime return of 1300
liquid token fund 484
but that pantera bitcoin fund over 65
000
through december 31st 2021 so that is
absolutely bonkers return from one of
the earliest funds in the space now the
fund manager is about 5.6 billion
dollars at the start of this year and
they just raised a fourth fund of about
600 million dollars in november they
have made investments in everything from
bitcoin to also exchanges like ftx
coinbase gemini oasis labs they've a big
investor in anchorage digital and many
many more we have this quote from dan
himself the founder and ceo of pantera
capital said blockchain is now being
driven by all the excess money printing
going on in the world tend to believe
that and of course in addition to the
pantera bitcoin fund what you can see is
that they have a number of different
venture funds the first one 51 percent
irr the second one 37 and the third one
in 2018 119
irr now this is not indicative of any
sort of endorsement of pantera or of any
other fund what this does illustrate
though is that these are banana land
returns these are absolutely ridiculous
video game numbers some may say but that
is what happens when you get people with
the courage and conviction to see a
secular trend happening to act before
others and to get ahead and to make
smart intelligent investments in the
right assets that pantera bitcoin fund
up 65 000
and a number of these other funds with
irrs as high as 120 percent pretty
freaking cool to actually get the return
data of some of these assets john what
do you think about this when you saw it
i think it's also really impressive to
know that dan went from being a macro
headphone jack uh pantera from a macro
hedge fund into the bitcoin space and
within this time frame he has returned
65 000 on his bitcoin fund alone but he
also has investments into all those
different exchanges he um
i mean he has investment into oasis labs
and other other companies in the bitcoin
space in cryptocurrency space so it's
really impressive to see him kind of
switch gears in the last decade and go
all in on bitcoin um at least from what
we're seeing here but
kudos to him right like when you make a
high convection bet or if you just make
a bet early on in a technology like
bitcoin and you can reap the benefits of
it um he's done a really good job of it
joe 65 000 is insane
that that's wild uh that's really cool i
mean he i think he heard about bitcoin
when 2011 started the fun in 2013. so
it's not surprising that he has outsized
returns considering the rest of the
market and when he got into bitcoin and
uh started investing he's obviously done
well with bitcoin itself but he's
invested in infrastructure and a bunch
of the exchanges so he's seen a bunch of
appreciation on the venture side also
but yeah i mean look it's it's uh
someone who left a job at a traditional
finance shop and started this firm and
invested in non-traditional assets that
provided asymmetric return so i think uh
ultimately if it would have gone south
he would have been made fun of and
people would have said you're an idiot
but he took a big risk and went and went
all in really on uh what he believed was
the future and kind of the best place
where he could park his capital and his
uh and the capital of his lps and
ultimately it worked out really well so
he's rewarded for that and i think it's
awesome
i think that what we are watching
is now the fruit of labor right people
who had the courage and conviction they
went they got educated they acted and
now what we're seeing is kind of the
outcome of the first iteration but i
think that when you have disruptive
technology you're going to get a second
iteration the third iteration right if
you think of the internet being early in
the late 80s early 90s that paid off
being in the early 2000s that paid off
also the mobile web in the 2000 early
2000s that paid off and so there's
multiple iterations of this as as it
goes and so it's gonna be really
interesting to see kind of the second
and third iteration impact of uh of this
technology as well right
i agree 65 000 not bad
facts